dans les caraïbes c'était une petite île
paradisiaque
[Musique]
90 kilomètres carrés
cocotiers et plages de sable fin
au fil des années ce paysage de rêve est
devenu un endroit privilégié pour les
touristes du monde entier
[Musique]
saint martin
une île scindé en deux parties un côté
français au nord et un autre landais au
sud
soixante seize mille habitants il vivait
paisiblement
jusqu'à ce que deux catastrophes fasse
tout bascule et
irma
[Musique]
le 5 septembre dernier un ouragan d'une
violence inouïe balaye lille
les rafales de vent dépasse les 3 160
kilomètres heure
bilan au moins 14 morts et 8000
personnes obligées de fuir
rien de plus rien c'est complètement
détruit je peut plus habiter dans la
maison j'ai plus de plus de maison plus
eu plus de vêtements fin déploré
aujourd'hui la carte postale s'est
transformé en enfer
immeubles éventrés voitures détruites
mêmes bateaux échoués sur les routes
[Musique]
le paysage ressemble à une immense
décharge à ciel ouvert
aujourd'hui il faut se reconstruire et
tout reconstruire pierre après pierre
pour redonner vie à saint martin
[Musique]
face à ce chantier titanesque
castor un jeune militaire se bat pour
déblayer son île
le dr murray qui a perdu son cabinet
médical prodiguent les premiers soins à
même la rue
si je me rate eyoum encore
je prends la tension
vingt trois personnes qui s'arrêtent
quête lille élève en terminale elle se
bat pour garder le moral à grand renfort
de mots positifs collé sur son
frigidaire
j'étais vraiment en dépression
[Musique]
pour rebâtir sur martin il faut déployer
des moyens colossaux
du coup l'état français envoyé le
tonnerre
l'un des plus grands navires de la
marine nationale
qu'il est chargé d'organiser un
gigantesque débarquement
attention sur bâbord
plus d'une centaine d'engins lourds
mais aussi des vivres de l'eau du
carburant des médicaments transporté par
hélicoptère
alors messieurs à ceux qui on est là
dans les poches vous prenez les sacs
voulait dégager 5 128 militaires
participent à l'effort de reconstruction
et tu me mets dans tout et où la barre
où tu veux
sur le port document il ya un listing de
tous qui est censé arriver tout ça sur
le port document la porte documents tu
regardais après les trophées première
paie
l'art par heure les en jacquard et
le fusilier marin greg dirigé
l'opération une tâche immense
arène là on est en plein dedans donc
quand vous avez vu en l'espace d'une
vingtaine de minutes il ya beaucoup de
choses qui se seront à la fin de
l'aménagement de terrasses à la fois des
véhicules chauny et qui par là on est en
train de finir l'aménagement de plage va
voir ce qu'il faut pour pour la sueur en
donner pour aider un peu tous ces gens
qui se retrouvent démunis donc voilà
tout le monde tout le monde est là et on
est bien content et ça va être efficace
tout ce temps là
il faudra plus de deux jours pour
débarquer mille tonnes de matériel
une opération militaire pour une île en
état d'urgence
dans la partie française trente six
mille cinq cents habitants ont subi de
plein fouet la tempête un désastre pour
des milliers de personnes six
propriétaires sur 10 n'était pas assurée
près d'une maison sur deux a été
profondément endommagée
voilà tout ce qui reste du jardin demi
cours et de sa fille kate line 12 ans de
plantation réduite à néant
c'était tellement je laisse à céder
muscade
ici comme ailleurs l'osce avait apporté
par irma a brûlé la végétation
il ya plein de jardin se maintient à
plus il ya plus
beaucoup de jardins
[Musique]
les pompiers sont venus ici ils nous ont
dit qu'on devrait pas rester ici surtout
avec des enfants parce que sinon voila
quoi le toit peut tomber à n'importe
quel moment on sait jamais ce qui peut
se passer le toit
qui est ouvert au milieu et puis après
il ya dans la chambre de mon frère il ya
un morceau qui est parti et puis ma
chambre y avait beaucoup d'eau c'est
catastrophique
en attendant les réparations kateline 17
ans se motive avec ses petites phrases
des mots chargés d'espoir bas ces mots
ce sont des mots d'encouragement que
jenny parce que quand il remet à est
passé j'étais vraiment en dépression
donc j'ai écrit pour m'encourager mais
aussi mon frère et ma maman
pipeau qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour
toi ça pour moi c'est de matour et des
gens positifs comme ça moi aussi je
reste positif
moi je suffisamment
défi adt et ma fille
pourquoi parce que l'encourager
malisse et que la vie continue et même
si les choses passent mal plus que tu as
le souffle toujours tu espérais de vives
la maison de quelques lignes de sa mère
étant inhabitable elles sont dorénavant
hébergés dans cette école transformée en
centre d'accueil pour les sinistrés
parmi eux des haïtiens ou des
dominicains certains en situation
irrégulière sur l'île
ici tous ont trouvé refuge
on n'a pas d'autre endroit
autre pour aller c'est dans cette
chambre que je dors avec ma famille la
famille de ma voisine et puis notre
famille dans cette salle de classe
aménagée en dortoir une dizaine de
personnes ont trouvé refuge
en seulement un mois c'est la troisième
fois que la jeune fille et sa famille
sont déplacés
valais dans des tentes
la lycéenne a vécu dans une de ses
tantes pendant quelques jours
tout comme 150 autres personnes
des abris de fortune qui depuis ont été
démantelés
[Musique]
pour tous les habitants une urgence
s'impose
avant même de reconstruire il faut
déblayer les rues et les routes jonchées
de débris
et pour ça deux jeunes ultramarins se
sont portés volontaires
ça elle est originaire
11 est-ce que c'est complet
les sections capot en pot
bonjour a tous
bien la nuit fut bonne
ce matin comme d'habitude départ mission
déblaiement sur les rues nous allons
faire le maximum pour aider la
population
d'accord hamida c'est bon
c'est parfait ah les sections bon allez
dans le dos
ces jeunes viennent de guadeloupe de
martinique et de guyane
parmi eux castor 21 ans originaire de st
martin
il est venu déblayer lille qui l'a vu
naître
ils ont six heures pour dégager
l'étroite route de grand case un axe
stratégique
l'une des routes principales de lille
dix jours après le passage de l'ouragan
elle est toujours bloquée les secours
sont ralenties il faut faire vite
voilà je mens
et mes cinq ans la messe à corneilla des
pelouses dans trois minutes commence à
charger on ne change pas les tôles en
premier et ensuite on met du lourd
dessus d'accord
est en train de par les huit heures à et
de lire les pluies si on avance on est
là pour avancer donc on avance d'accord
[Musique]
c'est volontaire appartiennent ou rsm à
un régiment militaire qui donne une
seconde chance aux jeunes gens sans
diplôme ou au chômage
quel sort lui a le sentiment d'être
utile reconnu par les siens
contre
son leader
[Musique]
vu que mon idée comme ça la loge et
peindre avec la comédie de la boire de
l'eau mélangée saint martinois et ils
sont venus me dire atteint notre rythme
bassam et invite le riz ça me donne des
frissons aux morts ça va j'ai tjs et
solidaire
à l'écouté
au bout de six heures
mission accomplie dégager cette route
facilite la progression des secours
une aide précieuse notamment pour les
médecins
le docteur merlet travail à besné clé
depuis sept ans l'ouragan a bouleversé
sa vie
donc il ya une grande vague qui est
arrivé
qui est venu se fracasser un petit peu
contre le cabinet
peut-être car entraîné aussi une voiture
parce qu'on l'a retrouvé là et la
devanture
s'est écroulé à ce niveau là où du mois
a plié la vitre aussi a valdingué toute
l'eau est rentrée donc je vous faire
voir un peu ce qui reste
la salle de consultation c'est
complètement
ya rien de plus rien c'est complètement
détruit ça s'est effondré les armoires
ont été généreux ont retrouvé des trucs
dehors
50 m 100 m
alors dans les heures qui ont suivi
remet à le docteur merlet a décidé de
partir à la rencontre des habitants
plus que jamais ils ont besoin d'être
soignées notamment à 110 grande un
quartier défavorisé
ici le docteur consulte bénévolement en
pleine rue
[Musique]
donc pour le tétanos et à l'hôpital ou
alors à la pharmacie mais pas dans ma
voiture d'accord la voiture allait y
allèrent conditionné mais il n'y a pas
de frigo d'accord si je me rate et joue
mon corps et je prends la tension
trente personnes qui s'arrêtent
vous avez des énergies non
ça c'est bien pour le meur pour les
douleurs au fond
j'aurais vu annoncer les pharmacies il
faut aller dans les pharmacies d'accord
le reste du temps
le dr berlet opère ailleurs sous sept
grandes tentes installées par la
sécurité civile on déplace dans mon
cabinet
j'ai pas choisi la couleur
et il n'a pas une minute pour souffler
et les soigner jusqu'à 70 patients par
jour des blessés d'irma d'accord
racontez moi ce qui s'est passé
il ya dix jours
on porte d'accord et qu'à descendu c'est
une porte en bois une porte en fer en
ferraille je veux bien un peu de
bétadine situe à chercher
ça vu un gros hématome qui s'est un
petit peu collectés donc on essaie
d'enlever la
le sang coagulé
tiens tu la tiens tiens les bras voilà
ah ah
une auscultation est normal il y a des
sécrétions dans le nez il faut juste la
lfr les soins d'hygiène
élémentaires et si ça persiste et bien
elle reviendra nous l'amener pour qu'on
regarde
il ya beaucoup des gens qui pensent à
quel âge mais lui il y avait quoi faire
de l'amour et tout ça je fais ça tu
es si le docteur merlet soigne
gratuitement c'est parce que lille
connaît une urgence sanitaire inédite
à saint martin partout il manque une
chose essentielle un élément vital
de l'eau
avaaz et à voter
certes et distributions de bouteilles
ont bien été mises en place mais dans
les jours qui ont suivi d'irma les
habitants n'avaient plus une goutte
d'eau chez eux
canalisations fissuré compteur cas c'est
tout un réseau en panne sèche
dominique
à faire la recherche de fuite pour le
réparer david poinard est venu
spécialement de lyon cet ingénieur de la
fondation veolia est un habitué des
missions périlleuses il a déjà oeuvré au
kurdistan irakien en équateur et au
sénégal
avec dominique ugolin spécialiste du
réseau local les deux hommes ont affaire
à une situation complexe
les dégâts ont été considérables
lorsqu'on a remis en eau le réseau s'est
rendu compte qu'on perdait plus d'eau
qu'on en produisait c'est
l'ouragan qui a généré des mouvements de
terrain et qui a généré des castes sur
le réseau et bien entendu dans les
habitations il ya des fuites de partout
il ya des salles de bains qui ont
explosé enfin même les maisons exposées
ont été vraiment se sont envolés et donc
ça a généré des fuites
et pour repérer les fuites il y à une
étape indispensable
rétablir l'eau quartier par quartier à
l'aide de cette clé
le but de ces pas l'ouvrir à fond à
prendre un prix
son livre at on
si on le voit pain
ça va péter la canalisation quand même
donc on va l'ouvrir deux trois tours
c'est dur parce que la pression de l'eau
derrière
on va le laisser trois pauses un monde
toutes les maisons que vous voyez par là
bas
vont être alimenté en eau
dans les instants qui suivent
rousseau de joie et nous embrasse des
fois donc
après tant de douleur tant de violence
l'eau c'est vital donc les gens sont
contents d'alors le lot vous laver le
linge de baisser pour la maison
donc trop boire donc
important
la pression est maintenant rétabli la
traque des fuites peut commencer et il
suffit de faire quelques mètres en
voiture pour les repérer voilà
certainement
et à chaque fois il faut intervenir
rapidement bonjour
une canalisations éventrées des milliers
de litres d'eau risque de se perdre
pendant que david et dominique
s'activent les habitants eux en
profitent pour récupérer le précieux
liquide
cette famille n'a plus d'eau depuis
trois semaines et pourtant david va
devoir couper l'arrivée d'eau
après
bien trop longue à thème combien keita
et pour les filles ici les personnes qui
habitent ici n'ont pas d'eau depuis
plusieurs semaines donc des petits bois
de l'eau arrive effectivement
les essayent de la récupérer pour ne pas
la gaspiller d'une part donc ça c'est
très bien
et puis en même temps là on va devoir
couper recouper lottiaux sur ce départ
et ensuite on va pouvoir réparer quand
tout l'ensemble des caf
voilà l'eau ne fit plus mais la famille
devra attendre qu'une autre équipe
vienne réparer l'installation
toute la journée les habitants vont leur
signaler des dizaines de fuite
à l'image de cet homme un peu désemparés
devant sa maison
[Musique]
mais maintenant s'il n'a pas la
comptable il n'a pas tout ce cas c'est
bon pour lui mettre le compteur après
moi j'ai pu y avoir branché dessus il
faut y mettre un compte à la banque
c'est perdu huawei
ne veut pas ailleurs vers
c'est l'asie
[Musique]
gola aux quatre
roues ce mois ci sont là ouais
franchement ils sont une grande aide
pour nous qui nous avertissent des
endroits où il ya des fuites
et comme ici nous avertissant plus
comment les fermer donc c'est un gain de
temps important pour nous merci encore
bonne journée et bugs
ouais
merci
seulement toutes les fuites ne se répare
pas aussi rapidement
dominique s'équipe d'un drôle d'appareil
il a repéré une petite mare suspecte qui
cache peut-être une grande fuite
sur son boîtier plus les chiffres sont
élevés plus la fuite est grande et
surtout et l'entente l'eau à plusieurs
mètres sous terre
cuite on a vu sortir l'autre sous terre
donc on suppose qu'il ya une rupture de
canalisation
ça c'est un élément qui me permet
d'écouter sous le sol d'écouter le bruit
de l'eau à dire l'eau fait un bruit call
rosso cryan fuite l'eau fait un bruit
donc ça dépend des des fuites ça me
permet de savoir quel genre de film que
c'est alors là c'est là la fuite eut
fait remarquer en gros la plus totale
doivent creuser et ils vont arriver de
toute façon
en fait ce qui ressemble il le fut
discrète prive de 12 500 habitants
allô allô te dis ouais ça lui c'est
david est ce que tu peux venir sur le
quartier d'orléans à côté du stade on a
trouvé une fuite importante à sion un
réseau
à côté du stade
ok on t'attend à tout de suite merci
david vient d'appeler un spécialiste des
situations de crise
teddy lauriers en quelque sorte monsieur
sos canalisations en détresse
et donc
c'est une émission très
bon allez c'est parti
à l'eba on va faire la prochaine
à bientôt et merci au courage les
traqueurs de suite s'en vont place aux
réparateurs
commencer par
tana fond on va partout ça casse de par
tous et
c'est le problème quoi c'est combien
compliqué à gérer
les embouteillages il ya les desserts
pas travailler on voit le jour en jour
ça va mieux
quelques minutes plus tard il faut
briser le trottoir
creuser deux mètres sous terre
pomper l'eau en permanence
pour enfin voir apparaître la fuite
[Musique]
seulement pour la réparer il manque
plusieurs pièces un nouveau casse tête
commence
on l'a le dépôt
irma n'a pas épargné l'entrepôt de la
générale des eaux
dans un tel fatras pas facile de
dénicher les pièces manquantes
nous sommes dans notre dépôt à ciel
ouvert voilà à notre ancien dépôt parce
que pour l'instant il est un peu ravagé
par le cyclone hier mais bon
on cherchait pièces pour tout à l'heure
la main ils sont ceux derrière la
balle et robinets bas tout le stock
qu'on avait
c'était bien rangé à la base mais voilà
c'est pas facile va sont mes
matches et le plus quoi dire quoi faire
autrement voilà on se débrouille on fait
des fouilles on cherche les pièces
sur le terrain c'est pas mieux là ici
c'est pas mieux non voilà pour l'instant
c'est comme ça l'a dit de façon là il
faut y aller il faut reconstruire pour
qu'on soit maintenant
fosseux des cyclones ise il faut il faut
avancer
chercher des pièces quand même et puis
on va retourner sur le terrain
attention c'est ça un peu dangereux
teddy a fini par trouver ses précieuses
pièces des écrous et un grand manchon
depuis le passage du cyclone il en est à
son 20e jour de travail d'affilée
waterman
eminem sur place après huit heures de
chantier
la fuite est enfin réparée
mais ce jour là plus d'un foyer sur deux
attend toujours l'eau potable
[Musique]
irma a déclenché une panne d'électricité
géante après l'ouragan pendant plusieurs
heures c'est le black out total
plus de réseau seuls les endroits
stratégiques sont alimentées comme
l'hôpital ou l'aéroport
[Musique]
alors dans l'enceinte de l'unique
centrale de lille edf a installé en
urgence un camp pour accueillir une
centaine de techniciens
ils viennent de corse de guyane ou de
martinique pour rétablir le courant
ce jour là ils interviennent dans le
quartier d'orléans un quartier
défavorisé
2 lire ok super de l'arrière là ok
dans ce quartier les câbles sont à terre
tout comme les compteurs
les techniciens ont deux jours pour
amener l'électricité dans cette rue
envers les galets en pause d'égaler la
cale
alors on va préparer le déroulage du
câble t70 donc du réseau basse tension
pouvoir alimenter tous les clients qui
sont dans ce quartier là voilà on a fait
le tour avec les collègues
on s'arrête un petit peu plus haut du
poteau piceno d'accord on y va doucement
allez c'est parti
l'équipe va dérouler plusieurs centaines
de mètres de câbles pour alimenter les
maisons une par une
bon là haut
et les habitants attendent ça avec
impatience
c'était difficile à ces derniers temps
pour vous
j'avais des enfants
étaient tous les deux la nacelle tu ne
trouves un endroit pour le cas ok et je
te ferai monter le câble d'autres aussi
sauté près ok ok on fait comme ça
seulement certains habitants comme ce
petit garçon devront attendre plus que
d'autres sont isolés 5 qui s'aggrave en
quinze ans
il a dit oui
toi
baudoux la famille on
pas partir à l'étoile hui d'accord mais
ça nous aurait fait ça n'ont pas fait
noka fini ici à nous qu'à dérouler parce
que après nous qui devons donc nous car
angers avant après le cabinet donc envie
ni ranger aux côtés ou encore dragon
quoi encore et puis nos quais nettoyer
sig un pouf une bête nous confie au
d'accord en fait la maison de ce garçon
ne sera pas raccordés ce jour là
car sa famille habite dans un secteur
isolé difficile d'accès
sans compter qu'à saint martin une
maison sur quatre a été bâtie sans
aucune autorisation
avec parfois des raccordements
électriques et légaux il y a beaucoup
qui viennent nous voir parce qu'en fait
ils sont dans les petits maison isolée
et parfois bas il n'y a pas de maison il
ya juste emplacement parce que le vent
le vent les a emportés et donc du coup
mais oui à chaque fois il y en a un ou
deux personnes qui viennent nous voir et
qui sont isolées et qu'ils nous disent
bah écoute
on n'a pas de courant comme on peut
faire donc on arrive parfois à mettre et
des fonds peut pas le mettre parce qu'il
n'y a pas de protection des habitants
isolés mais aussi des logements où il
est impossible de remettre du courant le
retour à la normale prendra des mois
en attendant du haut de leur nacelle les
techniciens termine le branchement des
lignes à chaque maison correspond un
fils différents
alors il ya celui-là qui correspond à la
maison qui est juste là derrière vous il
ya celui-là qui correspond à cette
maison-là qui est à moitié cassé voilà
et à celle là qui va pour la maison qui
va au bout de la maison qu'ils ont honte
et bars là-bas
tous ces branchements reste provisoire
un dépannage d'urgence pour une
population privée d'électricité depuis
trois semaines bons quand les boues et y
voit l'effet noailles la paix il appert
il a dit maman 500c noir c'est noir
metal/tissu prévient alors là les
enfants voient tous les clairs c'est
bien il a bougé l'appui ça va aller
mieux mais quand il fait noir
les enfants ça reste comme ça ici chez
moi moi moi je souffre et alors
c'était pour rien
[Musique]
cette grosse boîte bleue en bord de
route c'est un groupe électrogène c'est
lui qui va fournir du 220 volts aux
habitants de la rue une installation
provisoire utilisés dans des cas
extrêmes je suis prêt à le remettre en
service
je peux y aller
hamon céline exactement le réseau a été
raccordé ok je te rappelle ci est loin
de ceux ci à plus tard
il a du mal
mais ça va aller
bonbonnes
toc toc toc je peux rentrer c'est l'udf
bonjour monsieur
je suis venu vérifier encore des ans 41
ans car les oies si on y
cultive et à vérifier tous les compteurs
avant de touré lui mais
c'est la dernière manoeuvre qu'on peut
faire de notre côté on vérifier s'il ya
bien du courant qui arriva
voilà on a bien dû 230
sort je sais pas ce que c'est on va le
rendre plus trop
[Applaudissements]
tous ces bons vous êtes content c'est
bon ben si vous êtes content je suis
content aussi
[Musique]
oui oui voilà
trois semaines
eh bien bon
tu peux moi alors
à plus de viande que moi j'ai le riz
comme ça aide
le soir
c'est
comme si on allait susciter le fait ça
fait un peu cocasse quand même merci on
n'a pas ça
ça séduit
ses duels c'est la douleur dans cette
rue
les délais seront tenus
journée
ok pas de souci
mais trois semaines après herman trois
foyers sur dix attendait toujours
l'électricité
[Musique]
pour son dernier jour sur l'île avant de
repartir en guadeloupe castor a obtenu
une permission il a choisi de retrouver
sa famille
ma mère
je
il n'était pas revenu dans la maison
familiale depuis un mois
[Musique]
là on est chez moi ça c'est ma maison
si c'est ma maison
franchement c'était vraiment touché
ici j'avais la chance de ma maman là
j'avais le salle de bain au milieu ici
j'avais ma chambre ce côté derrière
j'avais la chambre de ma soeur est ici
récemment que si c'est le salon ici
c'est la cuisine si t'es pas content
mais c'est la cuisine voilà j'ai un goût
maison
est derrière j'avais un tirage derrière
pour aller la merde vu que voilà tout
est cassé valence
avait fait mal mais parce que nous quand
j'avais ces médiateurs ont demandé rien
quoi voilà on avait tout à la vélopiste
douchy elle avait à manger à enlever
tous voilà que là mais non c'est pas que
la famille d'odeur mais dopé des amis ok
ça c'est déjà bien pour moi parce qu'un
d'eau auprès des amis mais ça me fait
chier c'est comme si la famille dort
dehors parce que là nous ont demandé
tout fait à manger et tout voir
[Musique]
c'est pas grave ok c'est vous êtes bien
fini leader l'aso
baby baby baby baby les deux en dessous
un petit saut on va bien
voir tout mon frère et ses copains
cet expédient merci dieu la famille la
famille va bien
et y'a aucun blessé
ils sont bien voilà
et oui j'avais juste pour vous oui
j'oubliais j'allais fois ci avec son
camp restait pour la femme
mamie il a fait par ayew laissés ya fait
bayou
à lesquin est fait pour vous ok s'il ya
les petits bonbons comme tatem le bon
moment pour aller 18 ou à la
télé bon modération
je connais ma soeur parce qu'elle est
une fille
voilà on avait tout sucre ou quoi
et voila voila c'est la famille je veux
pas laisser la famille derrière
de son côté la mère semble inconsolable
derrière les sourires de façade le
malaise est palpable
[Musique]
herman ne s'est pas contenté de détruire
des maisons d'anéantir des bateaux
l'ouragan a aussi bouleversé la vie de
milliers de familles
partout
dd gaz invisible presque impalpable se
multiplient
des dégâts psychologiques
[Musique]
à saint martin un habitant sur dix
souffrirait de stress post traumatique
le même stress que celui subi par des
soldats à la guerre
alors pour éviter des dépressions en
série ou pire des suicides une équipe
particulière a été envoyée sur place
à l'hôpital thierry psychiatre fait
partie de la cellule d'urgence
médico-psychologique
son unité intervient dans des cas
extrêmes comme lors des derniers
attentats à nice ou à paris mais ici il
a fallu s'adapter
non
à tout à l'heure car les victimes sont
dispersés sur toute l'île du coup avec
ces infirmières ils jouent les psys
itinérant en maraude
ces maraudes servent tout simplement à
aller auprès de la population en puces
comme il s'agit de blessures invisibles
les gens n'ont pas tendance à venir nous
consulter et il faut pourtant les a
formés pouvoir leur dire qu'il ya des
solutions pour que le stress qu'ils ont
subis diminue et surtout éviter ensuite
un état de stress post traumatique
et c'est tout simplement dans la rue ou
sur le marché
qu'il va évaluer le stress de la
population on à la cellule d'urgence
médico-psychologique
moi c'est thierry je suis psychiatre
et c'est toi qui tient l'étal est à
recommencer il ya combien il ya deux
jours trois jours
depuis le début
j'ai dit depuis jeudi c'est trop forte
c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien ok
super
pour cette femme visiblement pas de
problème mais à quelques pas de là le
discours est moins optimiste
comment ça va
c'est ta maison
et oui
la maison en question a été décapité par
l'ouragan le fils de 7 ans est parti
chez sa grand mère aux états unis depuis
sa mère se sont anxieux
depuis chat ya réussi à retrouver le
sommeil quand même
non sa part ici retrouver son nom
ouais allaire la chaleur
oui le pillage aussi ensuite eh ouais
cette femme semble perturbé par ce
qu'elle a vécu ça t'embête pas de me
donner ton nom ton prénom et ton et à
date de naissance
après dix minutes d'entretien chéri
estime que cette femme nécessite le
suivi psychologique à res te dire un
truc g13 est rentré cacheront important
s'est situé à pas le sommeil qui revient
d'ici une dizaine de jours si tu
continues à sursauter au moindre bruit
qui te rappelle le passage d'armes à des
choses comme ça à ce moment là va
consulter ça coûte rien d'aller voir une
fois ou deux fois un psychologue ou un
psychiatre pour éviter qu ensuite ça
dure des semaines et des mois et que tu
souffres horriblement de manière inutile
ok bon eh bien c'est moi qui te remercie
bon courage
d'accord allait mais difficile de savoir
si cette femme se confiera un jour un
missile et pourtant thierry estime
qu'elle est bien victime d'un stress
post traumatique à la du stress quand
même elle a eu un gentil stress dépassé
ce que je veux dire et puis ensuite donc
qu'elle ait eu d'appréhension et puis
elle a un peu sidérée avec des
comportements automatique sur marjah
elle retrouvera encore le sommeil et
tout est donc je lui dis tu vas voir le
docteur thibault et puis il y aura une
cellule d'urgence médico
ces mesures
psychologique à fleming qui va continuer
donc tu pourras aller consulter tous
allez c'est reparti on estime à 4500 le
nombre d'habitants traumatisés par irma
pour eux le plus dur est à venir
d'accord allez je tenterai dans quelques
mois quand les psychiatres d'urgence
auront quitté l'île ils seront
confrontés à une pénurie de praticiens
seuls face à leurs cauchemars
dans le centre de marigot la préfecture
de saint-martin
la plupart des commerces n'ont pas
réouvert et pour cause ici les pilleurs
ont fait des ravages
les voleurs s'en étaient même pris un
secteur d'activité crucial les
pharmacies
alors forcément quand la première
officines de l'île rouvre ses portes
c'est sous bonne escorte
c'est la première pharmacie à réouvrir
pierre fils ont fait la queue comme tout
le monde parce que
irma a détruit huit pharmacies sur use
celle ci tient encore debout mais de
justesse
démarre on peut servir les gens vous
êtes tous n'avaient joué oui parce que
je vous garantis que c'est dur pour les
gens ils n'ont plus rien ils ont plus
rien plus de thouars plus rien mais ils
ont plus de médicaments non plus et la
plupart des gens ici soit hypertendus
sont diabétiques c'est une urgence
sanitaire
ça
[Musique]
finalement cathy pourra bien servir ses
clients
comme ce monsieur qui s'offre des paires
tension ou cette dame qui a du mal à
respirer
pourquoi
en apparence un retour à la normale en
réalité cette officine est à bout de
souffle
katie n'a que quatre jours de stocks
pour faire face à l'afflux de blessés
regardez l'état de la pharmacie et
regarder les gens ils n'ont plus rien on
a des gens qui sont en hyper tension qui
ont des taux de diabète qui sont
explosés si on n'est pas livré il va y
avoir des morts c'est évident l'hôpital
ne peut pas assumer l'hôpital n'a déjà
plus rien cote avant qu'on nous présente
les gens à l'hôpital ne pouvait durer
que deux trois comprimés donc nous ce
n'est pas réapprovisionnés derrière moi
je dis que dans quatre ou cinq jours
c'est terminé on n'a plus rien
sur certains médicaments cathy a été en
rupture de stock elle a dû tenir dix
jours avant d'être réapprovisionnés
[Musique]
essart idol
retournez à l'école retrouver une vie
normale cela faisait des semaines que
kateline les ses amis attendaient ce
moment
[Musique]
pour ces lycéennes qui passent le bac en
juin il s'agit d'une curieuse rentrée
deux profs sur trois et la moitié des
élèves manquent à l'appel de plus 25
classes sont inutilisables
[Musique]
mais pour ces adolescentes l'excitation
de la rentrée est toujours la même
dans ce contexte difficile
christian rey la proviseur adjoint tient
à motiver ses élèves bonjour à tous
bienvenue à la cité scolaire au coeur
des hommes imagine quand on est très
content de revenir je parle de nous
faire un grand discours mais par contre
j'aimerais qu'on retenu un mot c'est la
confiance
malgré tout ce qui s'est passé faut pas
perdre la confiance
on a tous vécu le cyclone de manière
difficile et de manière différente
certains ont tout perdu on ne va pas
l'oublier et on va même pas cherché à
l'oublier white chercher à avancer
les débuts sont souvent très difficile
pour certains mais n'hésitez pas à venir
dans les différents bureaux qui sont là
où vous jouez des documents payant
d'accord comme ça on va mieux connaître
ce que vous avez vécu et surtout vos
besoins
on va vous accompagner jusqu'au bout
toute l'année
c'est pareil
c'est un petit peu la génération et oma
ils vont jamais oublier cet épisode dans
leurs vies pourront le raconter aux
enfants petits enfants donc il faut
qu'ils réussissent
il faut qu'il se relève après ce qu'ils
ont vécu ce qu'ils ont vécu comme
quelque chose de très difficile nous les
adultes moi par exemple on prend
l'exemple que j'ai besoin de moi ça
travaille pour me reconstruire matteo si
ils ont besoin de l'école ils école va
tout faire on est vraiment tous tous
pour les accompagner
pour le moment kathleen n'a cours que le
matin
et pour rattraper les heures de cours
perdues ces vacances risquent d'être
raccourcie
la maca
95% de l'économie de saint-martin
provient du tourisme la renaissance de
l'île passe aussi par la reconstruction
des hôtels et des restaurants
c'est une course contre la montre pour
malori cuisinier en casquette rouge et
stéphane son patron dans deux jours le
restaurant doit ré ouvrir à marigot
alors qu'en centre ville
les deux tiers des établissements sont
encore fermés c'est que le poivron
tomate salade c'est facile ouais les à
grande marche et il y a il faut que la
catastrophe est pour demain
la phase de la séance qui vont dire ce
contenu
vous le plus vite plus on est en train
de regarder qu'est-ce que quels
fournisseurs sont ouverts là on va les
voir un des restaurants du patron côté
hollandais on va essayer d'en tirer des
bouteilles de vin aussi pour les rames
ainsi pour avoir du vin première étape
retrouvé des bouteilles de vin dans l'un
des restaurants détruit du patron
rien
voilà tout ce qui reste de
l'établissement
[Musique]
sous ce tas de gravats se cache un petit
trésor de plusieurs milliers d'euros
[Musique]
embarquer tout ça
de bonnes ça c'est des bonnes bouteilles
au moins c'est incroyable ce trop bas on
essaie de trouver des personnes et tout
ça parce qu'on a beaucoup plus que ce
que
du champagne mais aussi des millésimes
du monde entier qu est
beaucoup plus quand je pense moi je
pensais ramener un tir de sow mais au
moins là on peut déjà faire un bar à vin
même si on fait pas de restauration on
peut faire des tapas il faut faire
redémarrer lille pour faire revenir de
l'économie de façon c'est déjà rouvrir
les établissements et ensuite les
clients y reviendrons moi je suis pas
inquiète c'est que les gens ils vont
venir manger au restaurant les quelque
chose qu'on a tous besoin de faire dans
la vie c'est se nourrir et ça on peut
pas y échapper donc la restauration je
pense qu'on va réussir à survivre au
mois en attendant que les saisons elle
redémarre
[Musique]
79 bouteille tout ce qu'ils ont pu
sauver tient dans un coffre de voiture
les deux chefs sont contents ils
pourront proposer des grands crus à
leurs clients
[Musique]
c'est le grand jour pour malori son
resto est enfin prêt pour accueillir les
clients et bonne surprise il a trouvé
toute sa marchandise
et on a réussi à trouver de la viande
rouge la viande là c'est devenu de l'or
donc les gens vont chez le premier j'ai
envie de manger c'est de la viande le
restaurant c'est pas du poisson des
pâtes du riz parce que ça on en mange
depuis trois semaines déjà mais de la
viande c'est vrai c'est une bonne
solution pour les clients
christophe
on se voit deux secondes on va faire le
tableau dont il ya les escargots ou bleu
makrem fin à la crème de roquefort
salade
iphone os au chien
on a fait des prix moins cher pour avoir
plus de plus de monde et puis pour
surtout pour pas que les gens ils
sentent qu'on profite de qu'on profite
du cyclone pour augmenter les prix le
but c'est de faire plaisir aux gens
c'est pas forcément de rentabiliser à
fond
l'entreprise dans un premier temps là
c'est surtout de faire revenir les gens
de faire redémarrer l'économie autour de
marigot que les gens sortent puissent
venir manger se donner rendez-vous ici
boire un café etc
la carte à peine finies les premiers
clients arrivent déjà
une accointance fois une seyante sas
bleus
c'était quasiment sûr que le premier bon
il y aurait de la viande rouge donc nous
on n'est pas surpris mais par contre on
se régale et nous on la voit cuir on n'a
qu'une envie celle à manger
là ça chante ça faisait longtemps que ça
chantait plus trop là
on en mangerait bien à fait
mvr
car c'est entrecôte sur l'île tout le
monde en avait envie après trois
semaines de rationnement
pour égaler la
ces derniers temps à cause des conserves
qu'elle conserve que ce soit comme vif
mais cassoly sous les toits en conserve
c'est la première fois depuis aux mains
comment je bondis steak après un mois de
rations militaires
on apprécie énormément c'est vraiment
sympa de voir que les commerces seraient
ouvre de l'activité repart ça nous fait
du bien tout semble reparti mais un
imprévu va ramener le chef à la réalité
[Musique]
avaient ils ont coupé l'eau sont coupées
là encore la
voix la place
2 j'adore
royal avait seule affaire donc pour
qu'on trouve de l'eau on va en trouver
une reste un bidon la fille vivant pour
son premier service le restaurant a fait
trente couverts exactement comme avant
rma le chef est plutôt confiant
[Musique]
l'avenir on le voit pour nous on le voit
plutôt pour le restaurant sereinement
maintenant on nous on sait qu'on a un
boulot et l'a vu le monde qu'on appelle
déjà le premier jour on sait qu'ensuite
vais avoir du bouche à oreille et que
nous l'avenir il peut être que mieux
irma a drainé un nouveau type de
clientèle chez mallory désormais la
moitié des repas est destinée à ceux qui
sont venus reconstruire lille
[Musique]
sur les 1600 hôtel de la partie
française seule une centaine de chambres
est encore habitable
[Musique]
pour patrice seguin le redémarrage de
son établissement emblématique de ce
conte ni en jour ni en mois mais en
années alors là on rentre dans le lobby
gay la pièce principale de l'hôtel hall
2000 mètres carrés qui est un endroit
absolument fabuleux avec avec la vue mer
voilà irma et fait maintenant il faut il
faut détruire pour penser pour penser au
lendemain donc il faut nettoyer on a
besoin de nettoyer son hôtel et détruit
à 80 % et donc là c'est un endroit assez
symbolique de
2 des effets d'irma puisque ici sont des
chants voyez ici sont des salles de bain
ce qu'on a devant les yeux parle tout
seul tout est complètement détruit donc
là il faut il faut tout refaire
patrice n'a pas le choix il doit
repartir de zéro et n'a pu garder que
cinq employés sur les 25 de son équipe
fasse un pl de retrouver tous les
papiers de l'hôtel alors que toute la
comptabilité est encore en train de
sécher
jennyfer
ça c'est tous les documents qu'on aurait
vu qu'on a pu récupérer dans le bureau
de la comptabilité et qui ont baigné
dans l'eau de mer et pour l'instant on
les fait sécher à titre d'exemple voilà
ces documents qu'ils sont avoir du mal à
récupérer mais on va essayer de sauver
le plus important c'est à dire des
chèques
bien sûr
bien sûr un chèque soit 100 caisses et
l'argent le nerf de la guerre de cette
reconstruction pharaonique les coups on
en a une petite idée c'est aux environs
de dormir on s'est beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent
et comment ça va financer ça va se
financer
avec un partage des le public et de
financements privés et on peut penser et
on espère évidemment compte tenu de
l'ampleur des dégâts qui avec irma il va
y avoir des enveloppes spécifiques à ça
parce qu'il faut bien comprendre que les
trois départs de la relance économique
de saint martin c'est des énervés car
100 hôtels les cinq cent mille touristes
d'autrefois ne reviendront pas mais
globalement la destination touristique
il lui faudra au moins trois ans pour
retrouver le niveau qu'elle avait avant
si l'île franco hollandaise a
brutalement disparu des guides elle ne
veut pas être oubliés
les touristes vont vont revenir à saint
martin est plutôt en plus grand nombre
mais il va falloir être un petit peu
patient puisque là pour l'instant ça va
être la reconstruction mais c'est une
occasion aussi
un volontaire de repenser le projet
global est de réécrire une nouvelle
histoire et c'est comme ça qu'il faut le
voir
pour sauver l'économie il faut
impérativement faire revenir les
touristes et aménager les futurs hôtels
qui les accueilleront il est possible
qu'on
qu'on nous interdise d'avoir des
chambres en rez de chaussée ce qui était
le cas ici puisque sur tout le
rez-de-chaussée côté plage là on avait
une dizaine de chambres qui était
absolument magnifique mais voilà ça
représente une partie de l'hôtel donc on
va pouvoir retravailler quand même
autour de sa faute anciennement on peut
organiser
des espaces de spa des espaces de
bien-être qui auront tout à fait leur
place de devant la plage devant cet
endroit magnifique
combien de temps faudra-t-il pour
reconstruire ce petit bout de france
paradisiaque
certains évoquent deux ou trois ans
d'autres prédisent un chantier de dix
ans avec à la clé une île flambant neuf
une chose est sûre d'ici là saint martin
devra affronter de nouveaux cyclones